ティミグサンドゥ　皆はてぃみぐサンドゥ大好きだと思うんだけども
なぜ俺がてぃみぐサンディングを選んだかというと
四月は君の嘘っていうアニメで主人公が卵サンドを食べるんすよ
主人公は黙って卵サンドだ
はい、という訳で今回はこちらに主要なコンビニの卵サンド
全部買ってきました
まずこれを評価してくれ
これが俺の家に全部あるということは
俺は全部のコンビニに行って
卵サンドだけを買ってここに来たということだ
あのー
めっちゃ大変だった
めっちゃ大変だったけど　俺は知りたいんすよ今日！
世の中にはたくさんのたまごサンディングがあると
とぅまごサンディングの中で
どのとぅまごサンディングが一番美味しいかっていうのを僕は知りたいんすよ
サークルケーサンクス、ファミリーマート、ミニストップ、セブンイレブン、ローソン
ほほう
のたまごサンドを全部買ってきました
という訳で今日の動画は
"コンビニのたまごサンドでどれが一番美味しいか"
何気なく買うたまごサンドでも、
美味しいたまごサンド食べたいよなぁ？
俺の舌なら多分、
このたまごサンドのどれが一番かっていうのが分かります！
今日はコンビニに売ってるたまごサンドを
ランキング付けしていこうと思います
たまごサンディングナメちゃいかんよ
ただ簡単にたまごをぶち込んでる訳でもないんですよ
それぞれがね、工夫してたまごを入れてる訳なんで
果たしてどのような味に違いがあるかっていうのを本当に知りたい　マジで
まずは値段から見ていきましょう！
値段から言いますと、
ローソン以外のサンドイッチは全部184円
税込み198円です
たまごサンドの相場　今の売りのレートは大体、
ぐらいのレートで一応売買されております
ただ、ローソンのたまごサンドだけ241円
(税込み)260円になってます
梱包の仕方も普通のこの三角タイプと違って、
四角形のサンドイッチになっております
これはローソン期待ですね
今日の夜ご飯だ
では早速
食べていきましょう
一番美味しそうなのはミニストップなんですよ
何かオレンジ色のさぁ
半熟みたいなたまごも入ってるんで
ローソンもそんな特徴的な訳ではありません
最初の一個目結構大事だなぁ
いや　とりあえずサークルケーっしょ
とりあえずサークルケーから食べていきます
いやぁ緊張が漂うなぁ　俺マジな評価をしなきゃいけないから
はいきました！
"たまごサンド"という名前になっております
只今カゴメのチルド飲料と一緒に買うと30円引きになるということでセールも実施されており、
割とプッシュされている商品なのではないでしょうか
見た目はまぁなかなかですね
一般女性の20代後半みたいな感じです
食べていきましょう　いただきます
うん　美味い！
美味いぞー！
何かお弁当屋さんで売ってる食パンみたいな感じがします
たまご感もしっかりと出ているんですけども
濃くもなく薄くもなく
美味いです
ちょ、まだごめん、一個目だからよく分か
次はミニストップです！
テーマは"口どけあるしっとりたまご"
これは見てのとおり2種類のたまごサンドが準備されているみたいです
一般的なたまごサンドと
もう一つはなんかあの半熟のたまごが入っているのかな？
じゃあいただきます！
待って口どけ、口どけ
お口直し、お口直し
ではいただきます
まずはノーマルだな
う～ん　あ～　なるほど
美味しいです
ただ、サークルケーと比べてちょっとふわふわ感が足りない気がします
じゃあちょっと半熟いきます
ん～
なるほど
これは何か家庭的な味がします
お母さんを思い出しました
美味いです
次はこちら
ファミリーマートのサンドイッチです
ファミリーマートのサンドイッチは"フレッシュ　アンド　デリシャス"
"デリシャス　サンドイッチ　メイド　ウィズ　フレッシュ　イングレイディエンツ"
たまごサンド
テーマは"コクのある風味豊かな味わい"
これは楽しめそうですね
"風味"ということは味に期待しても良いのでしょうか
まぁ至ってシンプルなパッケージングになってます
では、下に引きましょう！
見た目はねぇ美味しそう
はいきました！
うわぁ　ボリューミーですね
これさぁ多分期待していいと思うんだよね
見た目がすごい美味しそうなんすよ
では早速食べてみましょう　いただきます
あっ　これは美味しい
これ分かる人いるかなぁ
ちょっと伝わらないかもしれないんですけど
たまごサンドって、このパンとたまごが
微妙にマッチングした時に
何かスゲー美味しい感じになるんすよ
何かこの二つには無かった、まだ来なかったですけど
これはそれができてます
"マッチングイリュージョン"が成功してます
伝わるかなぁ？分かる？
たまごとこのパンの絶妙な
微妙な狭間に
あっ　なんか出た
絶妙な味の感覚があるんですよ
それができてる　ファミリーマートのサンドイッチは
これはポイントが高いぞ！
"イリュージョンマッチング"成功してます
味付けかなぁ　味付けのせいでイリュージョンマッチングしてるんだと思う
美味い　今のところちょっとファミリーマートが一歩うわてに出ました
んー　かなり仕上がりとしてはもう極限レベルまできてると思います
俺は誰だ？
次！　ローソンにいってみましょう
イーストフード不使用　"MACHIcafe"からでございます
卵サラダ、パン、ゆで卵使用ということで
値段のほうがちょっと高いんですけども
見た目がかなり豪華になっております
ちょっと期待しても良いのかもしれません
オープン・ザ・プライス！ハッ！
おっ！　なるほど、なるほど
あの、ちゃんと作られてるやつだ
ホームメイドアプロキシメイトリーがちょっと高めですね　素晴らしい
これはかなりエンゲージメントのポイントに入ります